se verá verdaderamente afectada la
voluntad popular en las urnas el próximo
19 de septiembre cuando no hay
contrincantes a las elecciones del
consejo legislativo en hong kong
no no creo que se vaya a ver afectada
porque además lo que va a pasar mañana
es la continuidad de un proceso político
de 25 años que es cuando los hongkoneses
empiezan a ejercer derechos políticos
inexistentes antes de la reunificación
de 1997
ahora los líderes pro democracia habían
obtenido una mayoría histórica en las
elecciones municipales de noviembre 2019
precedidas por las multitudinarias
protestas antigubernamentales fue el
detonante para que china entonces
decidiera acabar de alguna manera con la
oposición
yo creo que el factor esencial que
explica el proceso no es la
transformación de ciertas organizaciones
políticas con con esas de
asia hacia movimientos que promovían el
separatismo en hong kong y pues -según
con
es un país es un territorio que hace
parte de la república popular china y
por lo tanto pues hay una un derecho de
china a mantener la hacer respetar la
soberanía nacional es un principio de
derecho internacional además reconocido
por 178 países del mundo que tienen
relaciones diplomáticas con china
guillermo con con la imposición de una
ley de seguridad de medios de
comunicación independientes cerrados
como el apoyo daily y unas elecciones
sin proposición como quedan las
libertades y los derechos de los
ciudadanos en hong kong
a hong kong es una región
administrativa que es muy diversa y que
es ampliamente conectada con el mundo y
la ley de seguridad nacional que se
aplica en hong kong cómo se aplican las
de las demás leyes chinas lo que
establece
es que no puede haber
en medios de comunicación que es bajo el
ropaje de la libertad de prensa la
libertad de información lo que hacen es
promover la sedición el terrorismo o la
separación de hong kong digamos ese es
un derecho que ejercen todos los países
del mundo igualmente
pero hong kong o no es
un país es uno de china no es un país
aislado ir y hong kong no es una región
aislada del contexto de la información
mundial
eso no es correcto digamos no es una
precisión acertada